Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér
Reinforcement learning is a technique that
can learn how to play computer games, or any
kind of activity that requires a sequence
of actions. We're not interested in figuring
out what we see on an image, because the answer
is one thing. We're always interested in a
sequence of actions.
The input for reinforcement learning is a
state that describes where we are and how
the world looks around us, and the algorithm
outputs the optimal next action to take.
In this case, we would like a digital dog
to run, and leap over and onto obstacles by
choosing the optimal next action. It is quite
difficult as there are a lot of body parts
to control in harmony: the algorithm has to
be able to decide how to control leg forces,
spine curvature, angles for the shoulder,
elbow, hip, and knees.
And what is really amazing is that if it has
learned everything properly, it will come
up with exactly the same movements as we'd
expect animals to do in real life!
So this is how reinforcement learning works:
If you do well, you get a reward, and if you
don't, you get some kind of punishment. These
rewards and punishments are usually encoded
in a score, which is a number that indicates
how well you're doing. If your score is increasing,
you know you've done something right and you
try to self-reflect and analyze the last few
actions to find out which of them were responsible
for this positive change.
The score would be, for instance, how far
the dog could run on the map without falling,
and at the same time, and it also makes sense
to minimize the amount of effort to make it
happen.
So, reinforcement learning in a nutshell.
It is very similar to how a real-world animal,
or even a human would learn - if you're not
doing well, try something new, and if you're
succeeding, remember what you did that led
to your success and keep doing that.
In this technique, dogs were used to demonstrate
a concept, but it's worth noting that it also
works with bipeds.
Reinforcement learning is typically used in
many control situations that are extremely
difficult to solve otherwise, like controlling
a quadrocopter properly. It's quite delightful
to see such a cool work, especially given
that there are not so many uses of reinforcement
learning in computer graphics yet. I wonder
why that is? Is it that not so many graphical
tasks require a sequence of actions? Or maybe
we just need to shift our mindset and get
used to the idea of formalizing problems in
a different way so we can use such powerful
techniques to solve them. It is definitely
worth the effort.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!